Black Panther is a hugely important
Marvel character hugely important in the
history of comics we deal with royalty
we deal with royal families but unlike
our other films it's right here on earth
you get to explore different cultures
and different aspects of our world Kevin
Feige preaching at Happy New Year
everybody welcome to 2018 so they've
just released some new character
breakdowns for the Black Panther
characters and it implies some big
comic-book changes so I'll read these
character bios then I'll explain the
changes from Marvel Comics some of them
are big changes some of them are
relatively minor black panther is
probably the closest to his comic book
self as you would expect he's probably
one of the most important characters
that Marvel's ever introduced into the
movies there's also new Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway stuff that I'll
explain at the end of the video but
important stuff so Black Panther it
reads as the new king of Wakanda
T'Challa is struggling to cope with the
loss of his father to Chaka but is
determined to live up to his great
legacy when Wakanda finds herself beset
by two enemies intent on the nation's
downfall Black Panther must use his new
suit in heightened strength speed and
senses to defend Wakanda in the rest of
the world when they're talking about two
enemies they're talking about Ulysses
Klaw and kill monger who even though
they look like they're working as a team
in the trailer have completely different
goals which will make sense once I read
their character bios here's real
research to see some of the big comic
book changes so Eric kill monger aka
Eric Stephens I know he has an American
name it'll make sense in a second was an
American Black Ops soldier who earned
the nickname kill monger while in the
field
however after disappearing off the grid
he is reimbursed with a plan that
threatens to put Black Panther in all of
Wakanda at risk using his charisma
considerable skills in combat in
surprising knowledge of wakandan customs
Eric kill monger is a dangerous threat
to all T'Challa holds dear so already
you're reading that and you're like hey
wait a minute mysterious knowledge of
wakandan customs isn't kill monger from
Wakanda well I think that they're
assuming from this bio that people don't
know that in the comics kill mongers
father was forced to fight for Ulysses
Klaw when he was trying to take over
Wakanda Black Panthers father to Chaka
was the Black Panther
at the time he wound up exiling all
those people so kill mongers entire
family was disgraced and forced to go
live in the United States so he grew up
in America and that's why he seems like
an American character even though he's
from Wakanda like people have been
asking how come he has an American
accent well it's because he grew up in
exile so right off the bat big chip on
his shoulder because his father knew all
about Wakanda he had to grow up hearing
the stories of El Dorado as ulysses klaw
talks about it in the trailer this
promised land being locked out of heaven
they kind of had a similar thing going
on with the villain of the Thor movie so
he grew up as this SpecOps soldier so he
has these crazy skills but he knows all
about the traditions of Wakanda and is
working with ulysses klaw to try and
take it over but it's a much more
personal fight for him because it's his
homeland
whereas ulysses klaw is just this
invading person that wants the vibranium
Klaw wasn't part of this big dump of
BIOS that they just released but you
seen in the trailers he gets his comic
book arm cannon is just a repurposed
piece of mining equipment so that's
where his comic book armed laser comes
from we learned a little bit more about
mbaku who's also known as man abe this
character you saw him in the infinity
war trailer working with black panther
so it implies a really weird
relationship over the course of the
Black Panther movie but his black
panther bio reads armed with hardened
Jabari wood armor in a battle staff
mbaku is a formidable leader of the
jabari tribe a groupable Condon's who
have shunned the use of vibranium and
removed themselves from mainstream
wakandan life in the wake of to chacas
death mbaku is forced with the choice of
challenging to chala for the throne or
joining forces with his would-be
adversary to defend Wakanda from the
malevolent outside forces so now it
makes a little more sense why they're
working together by the time to get to
infinity war so it sounds like they're
two very opposing forces but mbaku
doesn't hate Black Panther it's just
that within wakandan society a lot of
the different tribes have different
customs different belief systems in
different ideas for the future of
Wakanda so when you see this really cool
looking shot in the trailer here this is
of Boombah coos throne that he sits on
the Jabari wood that they uses wet
looks like it's going to be as strong or
almost as strong as most metal but
vibranium is still the strongest thing
probably the most interesting part about
his character though is the way they
shunned the use of vibranium knowing
full well what properties it has and how
it gives Black Panther a lot of his
powers Everett Ross's bios kind of funny
you know all about him he's the leader
of that Joint Terrorism Task Force
during civil war he's sort of this
antagonistic figure but less so during
Black Panther so he just helps Black
Panther try to get rid of Ulysses Klaw
because Klaw is the true villain of the
film so when they're talking about
worldwide threat they're talking about
Klaw getting his hands on the great
mound of vibranium and selling that to
the highest bidder so imagine all the
worst villains of the Marvel Universe on
earth getting their hands on vibranium
Tech and weapons it would be a complete
nightmare
shuri's bio reads pretty fun too it says
Sheree is two challahs younger sister
and head of the wakandan design group
which sounds like their version of Stark
Industries where she designs and builds
futuristic tech such as the black
panther suit in mind with vibranium from
the great mound she's an innovator
intelligent beyond her years because I
believe she's in her early 20s just from
the look at her so older than spider-man
but younger than most of the Marvel
characters it always ready to give her
big brother a hard time so comic book
backstory there Shuri eventually becomes
queen of Wakanda she becomes a version
of the black panther herself in the more
recent Marvel comics though she went on
a completely different journey into the
Dajjal eeeh and returned with
supernatural powers so obviously they're
going a very different direction with
the MCU version of the character she
also used to be Black Panthers
half-sister his father as Kings er want
to do remarried and had another child
with his second wife that child was
Sheree but it seems like from the
trailers everything everyone's been
saying that Angela Bassett is both of
their mothers so they just didn't do
that part of the comics we learn more
about the door milosh a so it reads
Nakia who's Lupita's character is a
wakandan spy pulled from her mission
abroad by her former flame T'Challa
Nakia consistently gets involved in
conflict for the good of others adamant
to use her bill
to help those in need and then it just
reads that she teams up with Black
Panther to beat the out of the
villains Danai gurira is character Ocoee
is the head of the dorm elijah her bio
reads a fiercely loyal protector of
Wakanda who isn't afraid to question her
king but would defend him with her life
a staunch traditionalist whose is
formidable with her spear as she is with
her tongue
Okoye finds herself torn between her
allegiance to her country and her King
when T'Challa begins to challenge the
ancient wakandan rules so you see why so
many people are challenging Black
Panther for the throne of Wakanda is
because you have people that still want
Wakanda to be the secret city that no
one can enter and no one knows about but
Black Panther and a lot of other people
also want to join the modern world
so biggest comic-book changes like I've
explained mostly with kill mongers
backstory Ulysses Klaus backstory too
just in the way that he looks in the way
that his character works inside the
Marvel Cinematic Universe there are a
lot of you that have theorized to the
kill monger might be a royal bastard
like secretly a brother of Black Panther
and that's why it's so personal for him
but that's not confirmed and there's no
evidence in the comics to support that
like he'll monger was never related to
Black Panther although Black Panther
himself did have a secret brother so
they could be combining a couple
different characters to make the kill
monger character the way that they did
that with the hella character from Thor
Ragnarok but no spoilers from that
there's still a lot of people
surprisingly that have not seen Thor
Ragnarok so we don't need to talk about
that movie so we'll probably get some
more information about that as they drop
new trailers so be sure to subscribe to
get everything and there is a new round
of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just share the video
using any of those YouTube tools on the
watch page there congratulations to the
winner from my last video
vanilla Bonnie please private message me
so I can get your contact details I'll
just name a new winner from this round
when I post new Marvel in a couple days
there'll be plenty of infinity we're
dropping in the next couple of days my
next video will be my 2018 movie prep
video so it'll explain what's going on
with all the big comic book movies this
year there's a ton of stuff coming click
here for that new Black Panther trailer
that just dropped and click here for
brand new and finish
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]